the situation is getting worse this year
we had no winter break 3,000 to 4,000
arrivals every day in Greece over the
Christmas and New Year period more and
more labour states are introducing
internal border controls let's avoid am
alkalizing migrants or refugees with
criminals and terrorists Europe will
provide protection for those who need it
but those who have no right to be here
have to be returned
well you smashed Afghanistan in listen
visited annoying
Suzette's in Edina Martino obsessive
Tatsuya my scores autumn doesn't annum
for Zetas fleshling a working strand of
economy and we will examine the
legislation and official respond to
Denmark once the law is a doctor junker
said that there will be a flexible
interpretation of the stability pact for
the member states that are showing more
willingness to solidarity what happens
with the countries like Sweden that are
not members of the eurozone
the Commission has you know already
recognized the different situation of
Sweden and has proposed to suspend
relocation to sit